hello there and welcome to this piece of
Internet so why they pour some beer out
and put water in it I understand we're
gonna do a little test test where you
take a bottle of beer then get rid of
the beer then put water in then give it
right back on tour right way yeah does
it just make the beer I don't know if
it's beer death
what does water do well what what
happened is that what will lift from the
bottom because the downward force
creating a little vacuum cavitation and
then when the wall catches up and slams
back down it'll blow out the bottom of
the glass pretty hard sounds that now
yeah no never before did that works
whose it works I give it a right way
look you see this science well you
really not expecting their toy I
wonderful good see your mind being
blowed lives on camera alright we're
filming this at two-and-a-half thousand
frames a second which is a hundred times
slower hopefully we'll see their bubbles
or vacuum in the bottom of the be able
good
but ready
[Music]
[Music]
all right well I think I'm some pre top
cavitation right there wasn't bad you
can play win some bets and borrow
something
yeah I can smash your bald just my hands
yeah and you uh you do it to impress the
girl you smash the ball and then she
goes what you're doing you idiot who's
broken beer the pub get out
I thought they'd say oh go back to mine
that was amazing maybe girls treat us
differently I think that's right
oh oh yeah all right how's it going yeah
we did pretty well thanks for asking
this video was brought to you by
audible.com and if you sign up using the
link audible.com forward slash slow mode
you will get free audiobook pretty good
there's actually over a hundred thousand
of them that you can choose from this
time I'm gonna recommend the Steve Jobs
biography because pretty entry I'm
actually honestly still pretty sad these
dead interesting fellow
also you should subscribe to the slow-mo
nice because you know you want to know
when a new Simon comes out right right
good click Subscribe
[Music]
you